jetzt haben wir auch witze verlegt
worden so eine zerstörung kohl statt und
da mit den gästen war bisher
[Musik]
da hat man gesehen dass die vorbereitung
mit k munition ausgeht und dass man die
ganzen schweiz studiert haben bei
manchen von schwarzen ist ein teller
frist war
[Musik]
dort haben wir befinden uns jetzt auch
filzen und der sich die schießanlage
kohlstatt geister moderne frage ist was
das leben da setzt die politik sagt
jeden schuss an klar
genau gesagt dass ich ein zehner durch
wort und weiter unten seit 43 blablabla
und so kann man die mafia einstellen
wenn ihr abgesagt so wie man es unten
vor geübt haben man geht es darüber wird
das rote fähnchen und dort so lange hin
bis zur klärung dass dann wenn es dort
wirklich zeit dürft ihr wieder in die
unterkunft
[Musik]
drei stufen vor herbert rohde im arm was
mit der kommunikation zu bieten
doch relativ nervös aber durch dieses
gute üben vorher und durch die gute
begleitung durch die bleibt denn heute
ist eigentlich reibungslos funktioniert
und mal klipp schock für affären
[Musik]